if you go just to human nature and human
evolution men were born to work and this
used to be known as hunter-gatherers
right men were the hunters women were
the gatherers men were men were out
there killing the saber-toothed tigers
and woolly mammoths and risking their
life to put food on the table for their
family whereas the the mothers were
raising the children and creating homes
and only in the last 30 40 years with
modern feminism has this has this sort
of been questioned and women work all
you want please but part of the reason
that you're talking about sexism and not
having enough time that it's women have
what are those things that that women
typically have when they get pregnant oh
babies a lot of times when they have
babies they they don't work for a good
year two three four or five years
whereas the man continues to work men
were built to work